hey guys it is the 19th of every my name
is jess mcdonald and i have absolutely
no stories today about frame rates or
resolutions i know it's like christmas
first up feel wednesday infamous fans
may want to clear out some hard drive
space because the ps4 install is set to
be 24 games we receive news of the meaty
game sighs thanks to an image of the
game's official european box where
you've posted on the playstation forums
obviously this doesn't come close to
Killzone shadow fall's 40-odd geek
install boats definitely a whole lot
more than infamous 2 on ps3 which came
all wrapped up under a 14 gigabyte
install what do you guys think about
this trend of massive installs and how
much space do you have on your hard
drives let me know next up this week is
all set to throw cheap games at you if
you know where look said place happens
to me the PlayStation Network so sorry
if you're not a sony fan for this one
Rockstar Games are having a sweet sale
so if you didn't have them all in your
game collection already you can grab
games like red dead redemption max payne
3 le noir and a bunch of their DLC as
well as bully at prices ranging from 250
to 750 if you happen to be a PlayStation
Plus user then this month is throwing
remember me at you if that thing you
want to play and you happen to be in the
US be sure to drop any other sales you
think are worth knowing about in the
comments down below so we can all revel
in the joy that is cheap games did you
know titanfall had monsters well whether
you did or didn't I'm here to tell you
about it so not worry we are pretty
covered off on the whole soldiers amex
deal but now it seems giant monsters
will be impeding your efforts to win the
day on top of all that the art of
titanfall book was posted to IGN which
alongside details on in game weapons
maps and storylines also features really
big freaking monsters apparently some of
these beasties will walk or fly around
levels harmlessly until people interfere
while others will attack you when you
just stare at them and I assume all will
attack you if you're trying to take out
a player character and accidentally
graze the height of a behemoth in the
crossfire corroborating the monster
evidence a post on NeoGAF suggested that
respawn themselves confirmed that the
Leviathan monster
better known as the ones that look like
brontosauruses will be present but won't
enter the maps personally I'd love to be
navigating dinosaur rathi in titanfall
but let me know what you think of the BC
edition either in the comments down
below or on my Twitter you know what to
do that's it for me but if you check
back with me again tomorrow I can pretty
much promise you another dose of views
so i'll hopefully see then